[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 25 juin le journal de tv
soixante dix huit pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale bienvenue si vous
nous rejoignez voici les titres est les
vacances approchent et les jeunes sont
sur le pont pour dégoter un job d'été
problème avec la crise sanitaire qui a
impacté de multiples secteurs
les offres mans pour cette saison le
point sur la situation avec kevin
information jeunesse
autre conséquence malheureuse liés aux
coronavirus le sidaction 2020 a été
annulée en avril dernier à l'an passé le
week-end de mobilisation avait permis de
récolter plus de 4 millions d'euros
l association très inquiète de ce manque
de dons appelle donc aujourd'hui au
soutien à la lutte contre le vih
interview et puis à la fin de cette
édition nous vous emmenons dans la serre
aux papillons elle a rouvert ses portes
depuis la mi juin dans la commune de la
queue-lez-yvelines sur place plus de 400
insectes à observer mais avant de
développer ses titres les derniers
chiffres du chômage ont été révélées
aujourd'hui en mai le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi sans activité
c'est à dire de catégorie a a diminué de
2 43% dans les yvelines
une baisse qui fait suite à une hausse
historique en avril en plein contexte de
crise sanitaire
elle recule sur la même tendance qu'au
niveau national est toutefois en trompe
l'oeil car il est dû aux demandeurs
d'emploi qui reviennent vers l'activité
réduite si l'on prend en considération
toutes les catégories le chômage a en
fait augmenté et concerne 560 personnes
de plus entre avril et mai derniers la
crise sanitaire qui a aussi des
conséquences sur l'emploi saisonnier les
offres de jobs d'été se font rares en ce
moment avec des secteurs de la
restauration de l'hôtellerie mais aussi
du tourisme fortement impacté yvelines
information jeunesse et le pôle jeunesse
de montigny le bretonneux accompagnent
les jeunes dans leurs recherches rendues
difficiles mathilde et demi
depuis sa réouverture le pôle jeunesse
de montigny le bretonneux accueille
trois jeunes pour les aider dans leur
recherche de jobs d'été pour ce jeune de
16 ans il faudra d'abord mettre à jour
son cv pour ensuite postuler
l'objet de sa recherche parce que le
recruteur il veut savoir si tu cherches
un emploi ou juste un job étudiant le
monde agricole le service à la personne
l'hôtellerie le tourisme ou encore la
restauration sont des secteurs qui
recrutent beaucoup de saisonniers
cette année ces secteurs ont été très
impacté par la crise sanitaire et les
offres pour un job d'été se font rares
je pense ça va être beaucoup plus dur
parce que pour les commerçants les
entreprises
la conjoncture est assez incertaine déjà
ils n'ont pas beaucoup de visibilité si
ça va reprendre l'activité va reprendre
à la normale et même s'ils vont pouvoir
garder leurs salariés par la suite donc
les besoins saisonniers seront plus
restreint après ils peuvent avoir au
bout d'un certain temps avec un surcroît
d'activité besoin de personnel
occasionnel dans les bureaux d'île une
information jeunesse tout se passe à
présent sur les réseaux sociaux pour
s'adapter à la situation des années
précédentes le mois de mai était décisif
pour trouver une offre d'emploi cette
année les offres arrivent au compte
gouttes
on a toujours travaillé sur des forums
avec du dating c'est à dire des
entreprises et les jeunes depuis de
nombreuses années on avait déjà commencé
à enclencher des réunions de travail
qu'on a dû annuler puisque les forums
n'ont pas eu lieu
on a voulu éventuellement les auraient
organisé en juin juillet mais en fait on
n'avait pas de retour des entreprises
donc les entreprises sont en train de
reprendre leurs actes leurs activités
mais n'ont pas tellement de visibilité
donc en fait aujourd'hui au vu du
contexte c'est maintenant que ça se
passe en fait et c'est un petit peu au
jour le jour l'année 2020 s'annonce plus
compliquée pour la recherche d'un emploi
saisonnier
il faudra patienter et rechercher
activement sur les sites plateforme et
réseaux sociaux pour espérer trouver un
job cet été dans l'actualité également
cette campagne de dépistage au
coronavirus lancé en ile de france
olivier et veyran le ministre de la
santé a annoncé la réalisation de tests
virologiques pour 1,3 million
d'habitants dans la région cela concerne
30 communes franciliennes est les
franciliens concernés vont recevoir des
bons de l'assurance maladie pour aller
faire ses dépistages dans des
laboratoires publics ou privés l
objectif est d'identifier d'éventuels
foyers épidémiques dormant rappelons que
dans les yvelines
on a compté jusqu'à dix cluster au plus
fort de la crise les yvelines où les
hospitalisations sont repartis en légère
hausse hier +2 en 24 heures quatre cent
dix patients sont hospitalisés dans le
département 23 reste toujours en
réanimation le
territoire ou 516 personnes ont succombé
à la qu'ovide 19
aucun décès supplémentaires entre mardi
et mercredi
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
2112 personnes ont été guéries de
lakovic 19 après un passage à l'hôpital
l'épidémie actuelle qui a peut-être
tendance à faire oublier d'autres crises
celle du sida par exemple 1,7 million de
personnes sont infectées chaque jour
dans le monde 170 mille français vivent
aujourd'hui avec le vih le sidaction qui
est à la fois l'association est
l'événement de lutte contre le sida est
fragilisée suite à cette crise sanitaire
en avril dernier l annulation du grand
week-end de mobilisation qui avait
permis par exemple de récolter 4 5
millions d'euros de dons l'an passé un
appel à la mobilisation est donc lancée
par l'association à l'occasion d'une
soirée une grande soirée proposée ce
soir sur france 2 on en parle avec
sandrine fournier bon soir dans ça alors
vous êtes la directrice du pôle
financement recherché association pour
le sidaction
déjà la lutte contre le sida est ce
qu'on peut dire qu'elle est réellement
menacé aujourd'hui oui tout à fait
d'abord il est évidemment important que
tout le monde se mobilise contre ce
nouveau virus le corps n'a pour l'heure
les je dirais que les perspectives de
vaccins sont plutôt bien engagé de
nombreuses et c'est odieux
je crois que tout le monde tout à chacun
à se mobiliser pour se protéger
individuellement et collectivement
évidemment il faut pas oublier un autre
virus qui malheureusement reste très
actif en france qui est le payage toulon
civils en syrie 200 contiennent
contaminations annuelles
il reste encore beaucoup à faire pour
notamment rendre le dépistage
je dirais un réflexe c'est très
important aujourd'hui parmi ces
personnes nouvellement diagnostiqués la
moitié n'avait jamais réalisé de test
un tiers de ces personnes
sans diagnostic déjà très affaibli on
veut vraiment faire et nous avons des
outils pour ça ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous redoutez qu'après
cette crise sanitaire d'autres crises
émergent peut-être des choses que l'on a
mis de côté pendant cette ce temps de
coronavirus que d'autres crises émerge
après cette crise sanitaire
évidemment c'est vrai alors c'est vrai
en france est d'ores et déjà le cas et
pendant le confinement on a vu des
associations en premier league pour
aller porter secours je veux dire mettre
à l'abri des personnes dont elle
s'occupait qui n'ont pas de logement
pendant sept manches évidement mais
aussi distribué des repas cartes du
soutien psychologique
la psychologie de cette crise n'est pas
encore mis à mesurer mais je peux vous
dire que sur le terrain les associations
étaient présentes au bout du fil
et évidemment au delà et ensuite la
capacité de sidaction a financé les 76
programmes de recherche en courbe
descendante projet associatif en france
évidemment est menacée donc oui c'est
très important mais un coup vu remporter
forcément à cette lutte c'est
l'annulation du week-end du sidaction
qui devait se dérouler en avril dernier
je le disais tout à l'heure un l'an
dernier le week-end avait permis de
récolter 4,5 millions d'euros de dons
donc oui c'est un sérieux coup dur
aujourd'hui qui a porté à cette lutte
oui même si nous connaissons de
différentes manières tout au long de
l'année évidemment ce week-end très
visible où chacun des médias vraiment
aidé un partenaire solide depuis
plusieurs années est très important
c'est le cas évidemment de thunes
collectons tout au long de l'année
donc on essaie aujourd'hui évidemment de
pouvoir rattraper un peu cela on
continuera ou là mais a évidemment
multiplier les occasions de collecte je
le dis c'est très important est encore
malheureusement tout à fait mais vous
l'avez bien des dons qui peuvent se
faire tout au long de l'année pourquoi
juste ans est primordial de donner à
quoi servent ces dons que finance-t-il à
l'origine ans de la recherche pourront
pas
de la recherche qui évidemment bénéficie
à la lutte contre le sida en particulier
je pense à des programmes qui sait mieux
comprendre le système immunitaire
mais vous comprenez bien que ces
programmes là le bénéficie également à
d'autres pathologies notamment on voit
bien que les essais sur le coni
d'aujourd'hui qui porte sur les
traitements évidemment porte également
sur un centre de traitement
on utilise un pays à genoux il y aller
il ya des ponts en fait pour la
recherche et on soutient dh mais
soutient évidemment la recherche plus
globalement d'autres pathologies
les actions associatives sont très
importantes aujourd'hui il faut vraiment
davantage cibler les actions sur des
populations particulièrement exposées
jetant sont vos actions qui vont
vraiment au devant des travailleuses du
sexe des personnes me demandent des
personnes en prison mais aussi des mais
aussi contre continuer la
sensibilisation en particulier auprès
des jeunes qui malheureusement on le
voit connaissent de moins en bien moins
bien le vih les moyens de se protéger
ses modes de transmission et adhère
alors tout de même ce soir une soirée
exceptionnelle sur l'antenne de france 2
qui sera proposé autour des comédies
musicales autour de line renaud c'est
une soirée qui est proposée ce soir tu
as fait emprunter fait inédit en fait
sens tant de comédie musicale revisité
avec de nombreux invités évidemment les
danseuses du moulin rouge
du paradis latin et de nombreux invités
pour wii revisité par départ des
tableaux fait sans en déterminer mais
musicale qu'on a tous en tête si bien
oui ça existe au rhic notre tasse et
c'était très important de la maintenir
malgré l'annulation vous l'avez dire le
sidaction aussi besoin de ces moments de
deux coups de projecteurs oui tout à
fait c'est bien l'objectif
et c'est grâce évidemment à nos à nos
partenaires à la fois le conte france
télévisions mais d'autres partenaires
médias et vous y participer aujourd'hui
qui relaie nous appel à dons tout au
long de la journée permettent d'appeler
le 110 e et sur sidaction.org tout mon
ami elles appellent à lancer quand vous
voulez lancer aux téléspectateurs c'est
n'oubliez pas le sida il faut il faut
encore se mobiliser
il faut se mobiliser il faut se protéger
il faut absolument dès lors qu'on ait
une vie sexuelle active
on change de partenaire être dépistées
c'est surtout ça qu'il faut réduire
puisque lorsqu'on est traitée tôt on met
une bonne espérance de vie aujourd'hui
et on ne transmet plus le bien du vih ni
vraiment responsabiliser et surtout il
faut il faut faire davantage d'efforts
pour que les jeunes soient qui sont dans
des intéressant puisqu'il nous
n'entendons plus l'écho médiatique tout
au long de l'année comme autrefois de 2
voilà de ce virus
il faut que les jeunes continuent à se
faire plaisir il faut évidemment qui
profitent du déconfinement mais surtout
surtout qu'ils gardent avec des réflexes
très anti tht et qu'il requis ces
recours au dépistage des langues qu'ils
ont une vie sexuelle et comment peut-on
donner justement dernière question
aujourd'hui est seulement aujourd'hui en
appelant le 110 tout au long de l'année
sur sidaction.org et sinon vous pouvez
pas faire aussi un petit don de 500 go
en comble en entamant doux avec sur
votre téléphone portable au 92 110 et
des biens qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci sandrine fournier d'avoir
été avec nous et je rappelle que vous
êtes la directrice du pôle financement
recherché association pour le sidaction
ce rendez vous à ne pas manquer ce soir
21h05 sur france 2 une grande soirée
musicale en faveur de la lutte contre le
sida
[Musique]
le second tour des élections municipales
c'est dans 3 jours les électeurs de 45
communes des yvelines ont rendez vous
aux urnes
parmi elles les clayes sous bois ou
trois candidats se font face notamment
philippe dit guen premier adjoint tête
de liste des claies avec vous 2020 il
s'est placé en première position lors du
premier tour et nous lui avons donné
deux minutes pour vous convaincre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est une équipe expérimentée et
compétente puisqu'elle regroupe la
majorité des adjoints et conseillers
municipaux actuels néanmoins c'est une
liste que j'ai voulu largement
renouvelée afin de dynamiser sur de
nouvelles actions
c'est une liste aussi que j'ai voulu
diversifier pour agir au nom de toutes
les générations tous les quartiers et
enfin c'est pour l'ensemble de ces
raisons que nous avons également obtenu
les soutiens majeurs que sont ceux de
madame la présidente de la région
valérie pécresse du président du
département ainsi que du président de
notre agglomération saint quentin en
yvelines et de madame coltman berger
maire de plaisir
[Applaudissements]
difficile de donner un seul point phare
parmi 140 engagement distillées sur 13
thèmes sachant que notre objectif
général et le mieux vivre ensemble une
maison pluridisciplinaire de santé qui
était un de nos objectifs annoncés dès
le début de la campagne c'est à dire il
y a un an
un volet très important surtout ce qui
est écouté et démocratie participative
est enfin très important aussi pour la
vie locale
un partenariat très actif avec nos
commerçants locaux et pour terminer un
volet de sécurité et de prévention
[Applaudissements]
ma première décision en tant que maire
sera de faire voter le budget avec pour
la dixième année consécutive un maintien
des taux de fiscalité locale
cet objectif est de permettre de lancer
simultanément toutes les actions
nécessaires est prioritaire suite à la
crise que nous venons de venir avec tous
les impacts sociaux et par exemple la
création d'une délégation à l'emploi la
création d'une délégation à la santé et
la création d'une délégation à la
transition écologique
[Applaudissements]
et puis à rambouillet c'est une
triangulaire également pour ce second
tour gilles schmitt est arrivée en
troisième position le 15 mars dernier
avec la liste génération rambouillet et
deux minutes aussi pour lui afin de vous
convaincre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une liste qui ressemble à
rambouillet c'est une liste citoyenne et
de rassemblement génération rambouillet
est une équipe entièrement renouvelée
issus de la société civile renforcée par
la présence d'élus d'expérience pour ma
part je m'appuie sur mon expérience de
maire adjoint et d'un vice-président de
l'agglomération rambouillet situé liste
composée de femmes et d'hommes d'univers
professionnels et de quartiers
différents de toutes les générations est
prêt à insuffler une nouvelle dynamique
et pour la plupart dont deux déjà
engagés et investit dans le tissu
associatif au service des rambos liten
et des embolies temps là le point phare
de notre programme réside dans le fait
qu'il est résolument vers une à
l'engagement de transition écologique
il est intergénérationnel est il et
mitry financièrement but he is la
première décision tempère bas peut pas
il peut pas l'avoir tunnel à la première
décision sera bien sûr actualité oblige
à l'accueil des plus jeunes pour leur
propose des activités dans les
meilleures conditions possibles pour cet
été ça sera aussi de préparer la rentrée
scolaire dans un cadre plus serein pour
démarrer une nouvelle année scolaire et
enfin d'accompagner d'aider tous les
acteurs économiques commerçants artisans
entreprises du territoire en renforçant
immédiatement l'économie de proximité
relancer la préférence du consommer
local et de reprendre au plus vite aux
investissements nécessaires à la relance
économique
[Applaudissements]
ne manquez pas ce soir l'ultime numéro
de nos débats en vue du scrutin ce jeudi
ce sont les candidats de la ville de
trappes qui se prête à l'exercice débat
à avoir sur tv 78 et aussi à écouter sur
les ondes de sensations yvelines
fréquence 98 points 4 et pour vivre ce
second tour des élections municipales tv
78 en association avec radio sensations
vous propose une soirée spéciale en
direct dimanche
révélation des résultats réactions
analyses et duplex depuis les communes
concernées
c'est à suivre à partir de 19h45 cet
incendie a plaisir le restaurant la
maison des bois a été ravagé par un
incendie la nuit dernière le feu s'est
déclaré vers une heure du matin et a
nécessité l'intervention de 32 sapeurs
pompiers des yvelines
l'origine du sinistre est encore à
déterminer 10 salariés de cet
établissement ouvert depuis 1926 sont
placés en chômage partiel
le chef espère une reprise d'activité
d'ici trois à quatre mois
quelques jours de galère en perspective
si vous empruntez le rer b un train sans
voyageurs a déraillé mercredi soir en
gare de denfert rochereau à paris
conséquence un trafic fortement perturbé
sur la ligne qui dessert en terminus au
sud saint rémy les chevreuse plus de
trains entre la place et denfert
rochereau un service de bus de
remplacement est assurée est la ratp ne
parle pas d'un retour à la normale avant
samedi
bajeux culture à présent dans ce journal
un secteur qui est toujours dans le flou
avec la crise sanitaire à saint quentin
en yvelines les saisons des théâtres et
salles sont terminés mais les artistes
commencent tout de même à reprendre le
chemin des planches
exemple avec un danseur et un comédien
le reportage de mélanie poker
on n'a pas le temps s'est cassé vendredi
12 juin sur tf1 les artistes se
succèdent pour être la chanson de
l'année avec des danseurs l'un d'entre
eux est vie si noah christophe ouest
formée à illicites dance a vécu cette
émission comme une bouffée d'air frais
c'était une vraie chance de pouvoir
travailler même si t'es qu'une semaine
sans on prend c'est toujours mieux que
rien pendant cette période-là d'ailleurs
ils nous l'ont dit qu'on était assez
chanceux parce que pour les artistes
intermittents du spectacle voilà il n'ya
pas grand chose en ce moment qu on a
appelé tous les gestes barrières qu'on
pouvait pas de porte et pas de contact
physique dans les corps et donc on danse
tous à chaque fois un mètre de distance
entre nous du coup ça joue sur un peu la
création sur la chorégraphie eux aussi
vont reprendre le chemin des planches la
troupe du crâne compagnie
semi-professionnels saint-quentinoise
répétera nouveau ce vendredi la
compagnie est très souvent sollicités
dans les châteaux franciliens on a des
consignes de sécurité c'est à dire qu'on
boit à près d aucun point avec des
marques mais dans la salle de répétition
ça c'est pas me voir notre
responsabilité
donc là si nous ne souhaitons pas
emporté de marque quand on goûte ça
c'est à vous de décider maintenant dans
notre groupe
on va d'abord essayer de jouer on va
paître et la ville hier on va voir ce
que ça donne quand même sorte de
barrière mais le son ne causera pas de
la même manière
christophe ouest continue la création
débuté juste avant le confinement avec
son trio la troupe du crâne et dans la
tente des nouvelles consignes
gouvernementales
les premiers projets pourraient se tenir
en septembre à l'occasion des journées
du patrimoine à saint quentin en
yvelines toujours les médiathèques
reprennent doucement leur activité après
quasiment trois mois de fermeture pour
permettre aux abonnés de bouquiner
certaines ont mis en place des services
de drive c'est le cas à la médiathèque
du canal à montigny le bretonneux et
c'est encore mélanie poquet qui vous en
parle
les cent vingt mille documents de la
médiathèque du canal ont retrouvé leurs
lecteurs depuis le 17 juin le public est
de retour mais pour limiter les contacts
les équipes se sont mises au drive comme
de nombreux sites l'organisation été
repensé par la trentaine de salariés
toute l'équipe est sur
pour rechercher des réservations fairly
près gérer les retours via la botte de
retour la mise en quarantaine des
documents voilà il ya toute une
logistique derrière la prise de rendez
vous on a mis en place un accueil
téléphonique avec des lignes
supplémentaires pour répondre à un
maximum
aux questions et de demandes pour
renforcer les consignes sanitaires les
équipes mettent de côté les ouvrages
pendant trois jours selon les
recommandations du ministère
réservations sur internet est prise deux
créneaux horaires en deux jours la
médiathèque a reçu plus de 1000
commandes
on est un peu déçu que ce soit que cinq
livres par réservation ce que moi j'ai
un petit garçon qui lit très vite et on
aimerait bien pouvoir réserver un peu
plus mes bâtiments c'est quand même
mieux que rien et on vient le mercredi
et le samedi pour pouvoir avoir assez de
lits variés contente de retrouver toute
l'équipe
voilà que pouvoir pouvoir lire aussi
pour cet été ça tombe très très bien
j'utilisais beaucoup en fait toutes les
semaines je prenais je rendais surtout
avec les enfants c'était pratique et la
bombe à ça on emprunte peut-être moins
mai
on emprunte 5 médiathèque propose
actuellement un drive elles sont
complétées par le bibliobus deux autres
accepte seulement les retours avant de
proposer des services plus élargie à
partir du 7 juillet elle et direction la
queue-lez-yvelines pour refermer ce
journal les résidants d'une serre celle
des papillons vous accueille de nouveau
depuis plus d'une semaine est l'occasion
d'observer un spectacle coloré patrick
jacques de dixmude et michael ni d'euros
la serre aux papillons a rouvert ses
portes à la queue-lez-yvelines après
trois mois de fermeture suite à la crise
sanitaire
les visiteurs peuvent de nouveau observé
ces insectes de toutes les couleurs sur
ce site de 720 m² maintenu à 28 degrés
avec 80 % d'humidité et la magie opère
toujours
c'est magnifique parce qu'il ya
tellement de pavillons différents et
ils ont vraiment pas peur de nous donc
c'est bien parce qu'on peut les observer
et on peut aussi les prendre en photos
ils ont leurs besoins le fait de voir
les papillons liberté puisque pour le
russe est la première fois convié cette
expérience là en tout cas thomas aussi
en l'occurrence une serre aux papillons
qui a souffert pendant l'épisode du coc
vie 19 la structure créée en 1989 a
perdu de nombreux papillons
habituellement on a à peu près 700 entre
700 et 800 papillon dans la serre là si
on
on en a la moitié c'est bien là on a eu
des messages de fournisseurs qui
reprenne fortement les fortement les
commandes et des livraisons donc on
espère que l'on puisse réatteindrai ce
nombre de 700 à 800 papillon dans la
serre de nouvelles chrysalide devraient
être livrés dans les prochains jours
cette visite d'une heure environ dans
cette serre vous coûtera 5 euros pour
les enfants et 7 euros 50 pour les
adultes et demain vendredi c'est le parc
france miniature elancourt qui rouvre
retrouvez un reportage complet dans
l'émission 7 8 salles hebdo à partir de
19h voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité très belle
soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]